Ryan's with us in Sacramento hey Brian
how are you hey how's it going better
than I deserve what's up so I've been
watching your show for a couple of days
and I think you give really good advice
but I do disagree with your thoughts on
credit cards and that you know they're
just bad overall the biggest is of
course do we know the interest is that
on it but you're on the premise that
you'll spend more with a credit card
than was past now that may be may be
true but that's a general statement the
general statistics and it doesn't apply
to everyone there may be someone out
there who can get a credit card and pay
about the same price as if they would do
with cash and then that would increase
their credit score and you know such
yeah my great grandmother died when she
was 90 and she drank bourbon and smoked
cigarettes every day and she used to say
yeah these cigarettes won't kill me one
of these days and cigarettes didn't kill
her they didn't kill her she got away
with it other stuff killed her when she
was 90 anyone the Bourbon either okay
does that make it okay for for me to say
it sit here and say cigarettes are okay
absolutely not ah so your logic flow
doesn't even make sense how old are you
21 okay and well your logic flow is not
what you're saying is it logical it's
say it's like saying drunk drivers don't
always kill someone so it's okay to
drive drunk
that's your logic flow and so it just
it's not logical I doesn't work so
here's the deal there's been multiple
pieces of research done not just my
opinion but multiple pieces of actual
detailed in-depth research that shows
that people spend more when there's a
disconnect from the fact that they're
spending money emotionally for instance
when you spend cash there's one study
that was done at MIP that says when you
spend cash it activates the pain centers
of the brain
you feel it you have an ouch moment when
you spend cash when you spend with a
debit card it doesn't do it so much but
does a little bit because you still
connect that with the balance on your
checking account emotionally they smell
the credit card it doesn't activate it
at all and consequently people spend
more another example would be the basic
friction on Amazon you bought stuff on
Amazon I assume are you an Amazon Prime
member yes ok and you realize you spend
more because it's easier to spend right
[Music]
even spend that much on Amazon but when
only time I would spend on it is if it's
cheaper there than on a store yeah but
you get the idea that the easier it is
to buy something the more likely you are
to spend over the course of your life
now an individual transaction maybe
maybe not ok I'm an Amazon Prime member
actually my wife is I use her account
but and so but so when I'm on there I do
shop around like you're talking about
I'm a fairly responsible guy with money
I'm a multimillionaire the stuff I teach
has worked for me and so but the bottom
line is is that behavior in your in the
way you handle payments does affect your
spending patterns over the course of
your life over the course of a year
again an individual transaction maybe
not and to your point some people are
more disciplined than others but the
concept is simply this the credit card
is the cigarette of the financial world
there's no upside to using it only
downsides is it going to kill everyone
no but it kills a bunch of people and
financially speaking so why you know why
handle snakes why
you know rattlesnakes don't always kill
you when you pick them up but most of
them will or there's a good chance you
know there's a better chance you're
going to get bit if you fool with them
then if you don't fool with them that
kind of thing and so that's what it
comes down to and really what it comes
down to is not studying your feelings or
your opinions it's say let's talk to
wealthy people who have built wealth
starting from nothing
and ask them what they do with their
payment structure and here's the stairs
what we just finished the largest study
of millionaires ever done and what we
found in talking to the millionaires is
they pay cash for everything some of
them have a credit card and pay it off
every month like you're talking about
but none of them caring consumer debt of
any kind ever they don't carry car debt
they don't carry credit card debt I
don't carry any debt of anything else
and so I appreciate your opinion Brian
but you're just wrong that's what it
comes down to you're just wrong and the
you know there's no possible way that we
would ever tell anyone to use a credit
card because it doesn't cause them to
win it only has downside not upside I'm
not gonna tell you to drive drunk you
might get away with it but you might
kill yourself or kill somebody else I'm
not gonna tell you to smoke cigarettes
you might be my great-grandmother and
died of 90 of something else but it very
likely will kill you it's a proven thing
it's you know there's only downside
there's no upside and so that's it I
mean you know the downside is your
breath stinks and when you smoke you
smell like you lick the bottom of an
ashtray and and everybody knows it
you're something you're you know you
smell your clothes smell like it
anything else and credit card debt does
the exact same thing to your financial
world it stinks it up and you're just
you're not gonna win screwing around
with these things so again to your point
can an individual from time to time do
that yes a highly disciplined individual
would be very unlikely to have major
problems but there's no upside so why
screw with the snakes they're cute you
want to pet them
I mean why screw with the snakes there's
only one possibility screwing around the
rattlesnakes get bet or not get bet I
guess there's two possibilities maybe
you're really good with snakes what does
that prove nothing then proving anything
at all so we stay away from them sir and
I appreciate your call